see most people think success is a  straight line  i'm going to get out of high school i'm  going to get a job and everything's  going to be fine that's not how it plays  out folks okay this is how it plays out  guy decides he wants something and the  line gets all squiggly see right now a  guy decides over the summer hey man i'm  gonna i'm gonna get this job this summer  and i'm gonna make some money this  summer and then he gets distracted by  the first squiggly  i don't know what he's doing he's  squiggling off  because he's not focused on his success  he squiggles you ever use this term  squiggle  yeah man i'm doing a squiggle  you know i'm gonna go out and hang out  with the guys this weekend it's a  squiggle  it's off path off purpose off  potential and so he ends up in a bunch  of loops over here most people get stuck  in loops i did it  when i got out of high school i was in a  lot of trouble  didn't have any focus wasn't fulfilling  my potential was distracted